donald trump gave an interview to fox
news host steve hilton
after that 90-minute long cpac speech
on sunday evening and it was actually
interesting because
steve hilton did attempt to confront
donald trump
about the riots now if you watched
trump's cpac speech
even though it was 90 minutes long and
it covered a lot of topics
cancel culture how trump really won the
election
how trump is so popular in all this
stuff there wasn't a single word
about the january 6th riots at the u.s
capitol
that donald trump incited during trump's
90-minute
cpac speech so let's look at some clips
here from this interview with steve
hilton
here is hilton asking donald trump
about the reports that he was enjoying
watching the riots on tv on january 6th
and trump sort of weirdly tries to deny
that he was watching it but in so doing
he admits he was watching it exactly as
was reported take a listen to this
that when that was unfolding you were
watching
and actually you you liked what you were
seeing because you felt that it was your
people
fighting for you um do you get how bad
it was
and is there anything looking back on it
now that you would have done differently
that day
well that's incorrect reporting at first
i wasn't watching tv
i turned it on later on when i heard
about it and did a lot of movies
so if you listen to what donald trump
said i wasn't watching tv
i turned it on when i heard about it
well yeah trump heard about it
while the riots were going on that's
when he turned it on it's a very strange
kind of like denial where he's actually
saying the reports are correct
and then trump says he quote did a lot
of moves i don't even know what that
means but this answer is so silly
it's so obviously a lie clearly donald
trump watched the riots on tv
just like everybody at the white house
was watching them it would be crazy if
trump
wasn't watching the riots like what do
we think trump was doing
were to believe that trump went to the
rally at which he incited the riots
went to the white house everybody at the
white house every news station
is covering the riots tweeting about the
riots etc etc mike pence is being
evacuated
and trump is like what is trump doing
what would he possibly even be doing
other than following what it is that's
going on so of course trump was watching
and he's lying
trump later in the same segment went on
to try to blame nancy pelosi for the
riots somehow
but before doing that donald trump
falsely claims that hundreds of
thousands of people
were at his january 6th rally watching
him speak no but
we actually i requested i said look this
rally is going to be bigger than anyone
thinks
because everybody i see said oh we're
going to be at the rally we're going to
be at the rally
and it had a it was i think the largest
crowd that i've ever spoken before and
i've spoken
very big crowds hundreds of thousands of
people and more than that
hundreds of thousands of people and
more than that he still can't stop lying
about the same things that he's been
lying about for years
he's learned nothing and then okay now
on to blaming nancy pelosi
they took that number from what i
understand they gave it to the people at
the capitol which is controlled by
pelosi
and i heard they rejected it because
they didn't think it looked good
so you know that was a big mistake do
you i just want to know how you feel
about it now
no no i hate to say it i think it's
terrible i hate to see it
i will tell you that it's very
interesting however
when you see washington burning and when
you see seattle burning and portland
burning and all these other places
burning with
antifa and the radical left nothing
seems to happen nobody seems to be
bothered by that
so trump shifting to antifa
of course the january sixth riots
happened
when trump was president so did all of
those other things that donald trump
mentioned there trump then is asked are
you happier
without twitter and trump says well you
know i do have a lot of free time now
because i don't have to worry about
avoiding
spelling and grammar mistakes in my
tweets
and he also mentions that it's not just
that he's happier without twitter
his poll numbers are higher than they've
ever been
for him or anyone else i guess he's
saying here you interpret if you can
another report which may or may not be
true that actually since
you've been you've been stopped from
using twitter you're actually happier to
be off twitter
and i'm just wondering whether you know
the impact of your speech today not
being on twitter there's a sort of
trump 2.0 where there's kind of less is
more strategy that actually might be
something you want to see well it could
be i mean i
have much more time i can now speak to
you a little bit and
i can do things that frankly when you're
tweeting
it does take up time and you want to
make it perfect because if you make a
spelling mistake or you put a comma
in the wrong location they go wild he
doesn't know this or he doesn't
so you know you want to make it good you
want to make it but i will tell you i do
have much more time
uh i my poll numbers are high you know
i think they're the highest they've ever
been it's very interesting i had when i
was tweeting and you i know you about
tweeting too but i'm telling you it's
sort of very cool
i had a lot of people saying i love them
we love our president but i wish you
wouldn't tweet
it's true so that is that is really
something else
another strange interview my
honest assessment after hearing this
interview and also
watching the sunday cpac speech
is that trump seems to be kind of going
through the motions but he seems very
deflated in reality sort of desperate to
have relevance in political capital
again
he wants to be king maker for 2022
that's why he's announced
that he's now fundraising and you can
donate to him
to his pack to help people
get elected or re-elected in 2022 and it
seems as though
how well that goes will be a big factor
as to whether he runs in 2024
i have no idea whether he will or won't
run in 2024
but increasingly seeming deflated and
like he's not even really sure
that he wants to stay in politics we'll
see what ultimately happens and i don't
know if we're going to see
too many more upcoming interviews from
donald trump one of our sponsors
is susman and han sussman and han has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other supplies
to stay safe during covid19 and sussman
and han is
the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about becoming a sponsor because
their prices are reasonable ordering is
simple
everything ships within 24 hours and
they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
sussman and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated
over 65 000 masks so far to health care
institutions
shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars you can go to
their website by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you 20
off when you use the coupon code david